alors elle ça qui m'attend frère on va
sortir une appli combien 15 ans tu vas
pas des conneries encore non pourquoi
aller mais quel genre sait combien une
2cv moral est toujours 10e rang dans ta
tête toujours toujours bienvenu ici rail
va trop bien le jeu n'a rien à [ __ ] la
société gérait guindon de payer
maintenant notre titre des hercules
là bas se remémore on alpina on va se
taper un petit rôle mais je propose
quelque chose si vous voulez petit tour
dans un bar que je connaissais je ferai
quand même moi ça m'énerve
on les parties ont à localement depuis
et tu veut encore aller ou pas un putois
rom tu bois tu sais faire que du décor
bon elle prend 100 calories mais dites
moi c'est pas qu'elle prend le volant
s'attaquent aux lieux
dans mon lit
ça va les experts
remaniement pourrait pas quitter
carrément preuve
c'est mon frère ma vie pour payer sa
dîme toutefois woerth ou tout en réponse
à dit et moi ma croyance et ça